Ramzi personality dr. D dr. John Delaney
PhD in counseling for those of you that
are not yet been introduced to him
talking a lot today about anxiety about
fear and taking your financial questions
your questions about how to deal with
some of those things where maybe where
people are mean to you they're
inappropriate to you how do you react
how do you set boundaries in those
situations and dr. D will be with us
answering your questions so what are
some of the things that people can do
because like our team went home last
week so there's nobody in our building
right now except a handful of a skeleton
crew to get this radio show going in
case people didn't know we got about a
thousand people in the building doing
all kinds of other things have nothing
to do the radio and they're all working
from home this week and next week and
what kind of things people can do in
those situations too because that break
in routine can add to fear can wipe you
out right it's there's this part of our
brain that is so I guess trick to
believe that familiarity is safety right
anytime you get plugged into something
and it's new every alarm system goes off
right so it's just about setting a new
routine set a new mapping out your day
if you're if you're married if you got
kids if you're by yourself set a plan
set a plan for the day so like if you
have a like almost a daily agenda and
you follow that even though it's new
because it was a plan at lower stress
that's right and it'll take a couple of
days expect your kids to push on you and
find out how strong those boundaries are
expect your co-workers and your your
significant others to lean on you a
little bit see how firm your that
boundaries gonna be but absolutely set
up a plan and over a couple of days yeah
it was become your new normal right yeah
home schooling is now a way of life I
mean for a lot of people and is I love
the post I saw this week that lady set
up homeschooling uh we just started it
it's going well so far two of the
students have been expelled for fighting
and the teacher got fired for drinking
yeah the teacher got fired for drinking
so it's just it's bad but yeah I mean
it's a lot of people are experiencing
some new stuff during this two weeks
they're also experiencing lot job loss
right if you're in the hospitality world
anywhere you're probably at home that's
right airline
restaurants for sure lots of hotels
you're at home and you don't even know
if you're going back in a lot of cases
nice and airy and that can be really
really scary how do you manage through
the stress of I can talk about how to
handle the money through the
unemployment side but how do you manage
through the stress of that I think
there's a couple of things you can do I
think the first thing is to not curl up
in a ball right because that's that's
some of our default position and like
you said earlier either curl up in a
ball or don't start being angry at
people I think the most important thing
number one is to get connected to folks
and make sure that when you're staying
at home that you're still facetiming
with people you haven't talked to still
call them people you haven't talked to
showing gratitude to folks whether it's
to yourself or whether it's to your
neighbors are important to health care
workers delivery drivers and then
honoring your body making sure you are
sleeping and exercising and not just in
the media sphere right not just
scrolling all day if you're scrolling
through a bag of chocolate chip cookies
and through every possible negative
media account by the end of the day you
are gonna be miserable
you were just spinning that anxiety spin
cycle faster and faster and faster
that's crazy cycles going on high speed
that's right that's right yeah and
you're gonna make yourself nuts that's
right get outside and just go walk yeah
that's right get outside and go walk
yeah
and and there are places that are hiring
I mean it may not be the great jobs it
may not be perfect jobs that may be tied
over jobs right sometimes just doing
something do something is better than
nothing almost always it does relieve
there's some sense of I have control of
my destiny
that's right even though you we never
have a hundred percent control of our
destiny we do control the controllables
and you need to control those things and
so I saw George Camel one of our guys
post that these people are hiring right
now Aldi Amazon posted I saw a letter
from their CEO they're hiring a hundred
thousand people Wow Amazon's going
bananas
Costco Dollar General Dollar Tree
Domino's instacart Jets Pizza Kroger
Microsoft Pepsi Post mates Publix slack
Target Trader Joe's UPS uber eats
Walmart Whole Foods and they're all
hiring and so if you were waiting tables
two weeks ago you may be working there
and who knows you might even
accidentally find a new career that's
right I guess that's a Kim Coleman show
that's right and something as similar as
as it means simple as my son and I were
going for a walk the other day and we
just got a trash sack and some little
rubber gloves we had from hunting season
and we just picked up trash in the
neighborhood I can't tell you Dave how
many people stopped us just said thank
you hey can we join you hey we're gonna
go home and grab it was just a matter of
doing something we got to walk we got
some sunshine and we got some together
time me and him we stayed appropriately
distant from everybody but then we also
got to help the neighborhood to
something small something little but I
got to feel like I wasn't just trapped
in my house you know unable to do
anything right well it's hard to have a
pity party if you're helping someone
else
every time every tarda it's hard because
a pity party's fairly low attended party
one that's right that's right so I mean
if you find an elderly person and you
can that's locked in and you can find
out they need their shut-in I mean they
need to stay in because they're hot you
may make a grocery store run for him my
buddy Kevin texted this morning he said
this is a great opportunity for
Millennials they've got a bad rap
instead of making tick tock workout
videos they could call the local Meals
on Wheels and see how they can get
involved there or find other charitable
organizations that are usually usually
rounded out by older folks in our
communities who are now having to stay
inside me what a cool moment to rise to
the occasion and go help your
communities making Instagram photos man
let's get out there yeah well I mean you
know there's careful because you have
Instagram and so do i but yeah but um
yeah it's not it's not time for selfies
that's there you go this is time for
other E's or whatever you call that
right well start a whole new phrase here
but there is something that does happen
in the brain chemistry when you're
giving rather than brooding that's right
that that helps you get through the
anxiety and we get to choose which
thoughts we ruminate on right or which
ones that we're gonna worship and so
when that negative thought that fear
thought comes in you have a choice and
that is you're right I'm going to google
it I'm gonna go down the rabbit hole of
anxiety I'm going the the rabbit hole of
pessimism or we can say not today
I'm going for a walk I'm gonna grab my
kid and we're gonna head outside or I'm
gonna go I'm gonna tell my wife great
job well what happens is inevitably
there's a real problem and then you got
the light bill that's exactly we got no
money you got to put food on the table
and you got no job that's right there's
a real problem but what inevitably I do
and I think it's human nature is is that
we project that problem to its possible
worst scenario a month or half from now
that's right and you can project in your
mind the nation's economy or the
nation's carnivore carnal virus curve
right the curve cut help me with the
curve but um you know but you can
project the worry and it just becomes
debilitating stress when you project it
out in the future that's right and
there's plenty of people who are trying
to sell that to us as well right it's
like a full-time job well and and you
know in some cases they're just afraid
that's right
they're their friends and family and
they're there saying if you know if you
don't do this all of society is going to
die what kind of irresponsible this is
where people are getting mean right
because they're afraid right and it's
scary from a macro perspective what a
politician a person in government even
the news media can pull off if you can
get enough people afraid at the same
time in a while
this is how dictators come to power is
in situations where people become cheap
because of fear the fear that's right
they huddle in the corner and do
everything they're told and so I'm
afraid I'm a little bit more of a rebel
than that so I'm a little bit harder to
mandate my thinking but you have to back
up and put critical thinking skills and
go okay is the cure the problem has it
reached the point that the cure is worse
than the virus has it reached the point
that the permanent damage to families
futures has superseded their health and
for me I tend to go macro like you say I
tend to get two years five years down
the road and think of all these what-ifs
and what I have to always do is draw
myself back and say I actually don't
know the answer and I can't control it
that's right I can control is what I can
control which is me right now and I have
to be concerned about the families that
work on my team
and are they going to be able to pay
their bills because I acted responsibly
and kept this place running right or
versus am i putting their health at risk
that's exactly right and that's a
leaders position that's right I have to
make those decisions and you know in a
family yet to do the same thing and as
an individual you have to do the same
thing but no one makes good decisions
when they're panicked or drunk or hard
laugher says my favorite quote of the
year and I'm gonna use it a lot he sent
me an email last night a matter if I
quoting it again
so dr. John Delaney with us this hour
half hour next hour as we talk about
money
and we talk about what's going on out
there and your feelings about it
I got a coach got a counselor right here
beside me